[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola hola buenas tardes gracias por
estar aquí hoy día
esa soy yo y en un nuevo momento va a
haber una foto donde estamos viejo y yo
es un niño maravilloso como lo ven es un
niño guapo sonriente es un niño
simpático es un niño lleno de virtudes
es un niño libre le gusta correr
muchísimo bailar y al costado esa foto
no tiene fotos por si acaso me veo más
joven pero no tiene photoshop estoy yo y
la palabra que últimamente uso más para
definirme es que yo soy una mujer
feminista
cuando digo feminista cuando se lo
comento a gente cercana o gente no muy
cercana en las calles en mi familia mi
mamá por ejemplo también es generalmente
veo la mirada así como de
cuestionamiento como de qué pasa aquí
como de por qué no igual ismo como qué
pasa
y bueno he venido aquí para empezar
a hablarles de mi hijo y de por qué
quiero que mi hijo tenga una crianza
feminista y porque desde mi perspectiva
es necesario que mi niño tenga esta
crianza hace un momento el organizador
hablaba de igualdad efectivamente es por
eso el feminismo en su concepto es la
búsqueda de la igualdad es un movimiento
social que busca la igualdad lo
confundimos mucho con él como un término
que las feministas conocemos bien que es
el hembrismo
creo que ahí radica la confusión es el
término que relaciona más a la
superioridad de una mujer sobre un
hombre que no es real que no la queremos
realmente lo que queremos precisamente
es ir equilibrando las cosas
y para eso es que yo estoy ahora aquí
para decirles por ejemplo que como
seguramente muchos de ustedes ha sufrido
discriminación cuando era escolar había
una profesora que por el hecho de
vestirme o verme diferente me sentaba
frente a ella por horas la verdad nunca
supe muy bien el objetivo yo entiendo
que quizás ella sólo quería observar me
para ver qué había de complicado o de
extraño en mi se expulsaron chicas del
colegio por tener un comportamiento
alejado del ideal de señorita que nos
enseñan a mantener a lo largo de nuestra
vida se expulsaron alumnos del colegio
en el caso de los varones seguramente
han sentido alguna vez también que los
han descalificado por mostrar alguna
emoción que no es la ira
qué sé yo la euforia deportiva esas
cosas suceden todavía suceden y nos
afectan muchísimo a todos como personas
tienen que ver con los prejuicios y con
los estereotipos que constantemente
están limitando a las personas y cuando
se trata de niños se empieza con estos
prejuicios y estos estereotipos a muy
temprana edad se empieza cuando quizás
quiero pintar el color de la habitación
de mi niño y digo bueno es niño la voy a
pintar de azul o de amarillo no en jerry
ya rosado y le pondré la mayor cantidad
posible de unicornios o de princesas
bueno eso sucede y aunque parece
inocente al principio y aunque ustedes
dirán bueno el niño se va a pasar 18
horas de su vida diaria durmiendo ahí ni
cuenta se va a dar el problema es que
ahí empieza pero nosotros mismos con
nuestros propios prejuicios nosotros
mismos con
en la atención que le damos a los medios
a la valoración de los medios sobre lo
que un hombre y una mujer debe ser es
que reforzamos a lo largo de su
existencia todos estos estereotipos y
esos estereotipos con el tiempo generan
violencia generan disgregación generan
separación generan discriminación esto
lo vemos con mi niño todo el tiempo en
los centros comerciales no seguramente
todos ustedes niñas de rosados con
cocinas con muñecas
y los niños por otro lado con vehículos
con juguetes que le permiten un poquito
crear armar cosas yo recuerdo que en mi
infancia por ejemplo deseaba con mucha
fuerza que me regalaran un lego
y navidad tras navidad veía como a mis
hermanos a mis primos les regalaban
legos de naves espaciales helicópteros
aviones autos y yo los miraba nada más
pues no porque me me regalaban otras
cosas las cosas que son para mí en ese
proceso como mujer feminista que
reconoce la necesidad de igualdad y la
siente indispensable y necesaria estoy
tratando de llevarlo ahora a la crianza
de mi pequeña
porque he podido comprobar tratando de
experimentar un poco no solamente con el
juguete que tengo aquí que es una pelota
sino también con otros de sus juguetes
como su pequeño bebé mi nieto
césar miguel
y al mismo tiempo también con vehículos
y otros le he dado y he querido darle la
libertad de explorar
otros espacios otras emociones otras
formas de ver el juego que es lo
esencial para aprender las cosas en la
vida para aprender todo lo que importa
en la vida empezamos jugando para
aprender he tratado de quitarle todas
estas cosas que lo condicionan a ser un
barón como las personas esperan que sean
no a veces la misma familia no
compórtate como un varoncito y qué
significa eso deja de llorar
los niños no lloran
y me pasa también con mis sobrinas no a
las que les dice dentro de poco sí como
si el reloj fuera corriendo rapidísimo y
ellas tienen 10 9 y 7 años dentro de
poco te vas a convertir en una señorita
pero ya tienes que empezar a actuar como
tal
me pasa también que las fiestas
infantiles a las que voy con mi hijo él
tiene toda la libertad de espacio
posible y de movimiento posible y lo ves
correr con todos los demás niños por
toda la fiesta se golpea se caen se
paran de cabeza no pasa lo mismo con las
niñas yo no sé si ustedes lo han notado
las niñas para empezar están vestidas de
colores muy tenue sé que podrían
ensuciarse las niñas tienen unos zapatos
especiales que casi no las dejan moverse
las niñas tienen vestidos que si se
paran de cabeza se le va a ver el calzón
no horrible terrible que se les ve a las
niñas entonces estas cosas que nosotros
hacemos sin darnos cuenta y porque las
hemos aprendido por el sistema mismo en
el que vivimos son las que van limitando
el comportamiento de las niñas y
haciéndoles creer a los niños que
ciertamente todo el mundo todo el
espacio y todas las posibilidades son
solo suyas que es genial que mi hijo
crea que el espacio las posibilidades
las aptitudes sean suyas
eso es lo que yo quisiera que él crea
pero quisiera que él entendiera que ese
espacio es compartido y que en ese
espacio la igualdad es lo único que va a
ser que logremos un desarrollo real
verdadero una empatía real de los
sentimientos de unos con otros mi
hermano por ejemplo no se cansa de
explicarme que las mujeres y los hombres
no somos iguales los hombres son más
fuertes que los hombres están destinados
para realizar labores pesadas y las
mujeres más bien para este tipo de
labores que tienen que ver con el
cuidado y la empatía por un lado no
podemos usar la biología para justificar
pues no situaciones de discriminación
que devienen de esta supuesta fuerza del
varón y de esta supuesta debilidad de la
mujer
y por otro lado los que hacemos las
normas sociales los que desafiamos
pequeñas barreras en las que nos
encierran los estereotipos los
prejuicios los clichés somos nosotros
mismos siempre y cuando alguna vez una
madre o un padre nos diga que nos es
posible hacer cosas las empoderamos a
las niñas no es cierto ya cada vez más
realmente estamos haciendo cada vez que
las niñas desafíen espacios que no eran
para ellas
hoy en fútbol que parten más fuerte oye
tú no eres débil no te dejes no di lo
que piensas y lo que sientas y es
necesario pero los niños lo seguimos
mirando de reojo
cuando tienen una actitud a ver vamos a
decir de esta manera poco masculina no
decimos esto no les decimos oye ya
cállate no los niños no lloran por favor
porque estamos cansados de escucharlo
hacemos todo eso en la educación en
nuestra crianza en todo caso bueno la
educación es algo que vendrá es un
proceso que continuará a lo largo de
toda su vida y nos iremos auto
descubriendo e iremos descubriendo
también que esas barreras que nos ponían
eran ficticias no que era un producto
del desconocimiento de la ignorancia que
se yo
pero en la crianza más básica esa que se
da con amor esa que se da con libertad
que es tan difícil criar con libertad
en esa crianza está el que por ejemplo
mi hijo realmente tenga la posibilidad
de explorar sus emociones de que no se
convierta en un machito de lo que se
espera que sea de él no y cuando sea
adulto no tenga idea de qué es lo que
siente porque los varones tienen
emocionalidad obviamente no pero no
saben decir qué les pasa
que lo diga mi esposo que a veces
conversamos hoy y cómo estás
qué tal te fue cuéntame un poco
tranquilo y eso no necesariamente hablar
de sus emociones pero sí
y poder expresar no poder expresar un
poco más allá de lo que se espera que se
hable un hombre cuando entre mujeres no
nos enseñan a oye podemos conversar
muchísimo de las mujeres hablamos un
montón y podemos hablar de todas las
cosas
de repente los chicos por ahí no pueden
hablar de todas las cosas o no se
sienten cómodos hablando de todas las
cosas
en este proceso de crianza de mi pequeño
mario de mi pequeño sol yo he tratado y
ya me resultó muy pequeño para
mostrárselos pero ya que está acá he
tratado que en vez de ponerle
estas estas cosas estas características
estas que selló expectativas mías de que
sea un niño varoncito he tratado más
bien de quitárselas y ver una persona
así de ver un ser humano así un ser
humano en blanco un ser humano al que le
puede ser posible explorar sus emociones
hablar de ellas llorar el tiempo que
desee de verdad que yo sin afán de
decirles que soy una madre perfecta y
que mi hijo es el niño perfecto que no
es ese mi afán he notado que él se
siente más libre para abrazar que se
siente más libre inclusive para llorar
largamente y yo trato de consolarlo pero
ya me llame deje
me deje de decirle no llores más me deje
de contenerlo
quisiera que pasara eso con todos los
papás como con todos los passion además
quisiera que todos los padres
entendieran que involucrarse realmente y
equitativamente cuando la situación
laboral lo permite en la crianza de los
hijos es lo mejor que se puede hacer por
lo que nosotros estamos esperando que
sea el futuro no porque decimos los
niños son el futuro pero si la crianza
continúa como hace
años atrás y que cambio estamos
esperando y finalmente trató de
convencerme también que los niños no son
el futuro que los que estamos empezando
a crear condiciones para ese futuro
somos nosotros que ellos simplemente van
a seguir el camino que deseen seguir
para mí es vital vital que mi niño sea
un hombre libre y especialmente que sea
un hombre feliz y regreso al tema de la
igualdad y regreso al tema de la
igualdad porque solamente una persona
que es libre y que es feliz que siente
empatía con los demás que siempre
respeto por los demás cree realmente en
la igualdad y trabaja por ella
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]